I'm really happy to hear and read the
fan response to what we did at our
briefing we really wanted to come in and
make sure that everybody understood that
I mean you know I ran first party
studios I'm somebody who grew up playing
games I think about a gaming console
like Xbox or Playstation or Nintendo is
a place I want to go play great games
and for me this e3 was an opportunity
for us to come out and just really show
what we're about how we show up I didn't
want to take shots anybody else it
wasn't about that it was really just
here I loved the art form that we have
in games
I love the creators I wanted to bring
them on the floor and actually sit with
them on the floor and talk and amongst
them and have them come up and talk
about their games and show a very
diverse lineup the reaction that that's
been great you know that's that's why we
do this we do this for so people buy our
games and buy our console so that's
really nice the last year has been a
good learning opportunity for all of us
in the Xbox team this word in it to win
nobody should take away that we're not
competitive with Sony Nintendo
completely are and I don't want
everybody to buy an Xbox one like but I
think we get there through showing what
we're doing and what we're focused on
and not really focused on the other the
other guy specifically I applauded them
I thought they had nice nice shows and
it's nice to see the response that the
fans have had to our show what you're
seeing a resurgence now and I might not
even say resurgence we saw both the 360
the ps3 and the Wii U were in the market
for an awful long time it had tremendous
success now we've got Sony and us coming
out at the same time and you've never
seen this many new generation consoles
sold in such a short period of time
which is great success for the industry
I think mobile I think PC
I think free-to-play kind of more
accessible business models around games
or just creating more people that look
at games as something that they want to
entertain themselves with how they want
to spend their time and then when you
look at the very high fidelity things
that we're able to put on their
television screens to the console
industry and the power of today's
console I think it's the the amount of
game content out there the amount of
gamers
probably have more gamers than we've
ever seen playing all kinds of games
it's just a good thing for the console
business I think that's playing out
right now we have a good lineup of
free-to-play games on 360 and I think
it's an interesting business model and
creative mechanic for getting people to
play and things like happy Wars and
World of Tanks and we're face and stuff
on 360 I've done really well early on in
a new generation like we are with with
Xbox one you're free to play as a model
really requires a lot of people that's
how the whole model works because you're
going to monetize such a smaller set
we've embraced free-to-play long ago in
the console space and will continue to
do that I think it's an interesting form
of gaming and I see a lot of innovation
there and something that I think it will
be here to stay you talk about the
multiple price points in the multiple
ways that we monetize games today I
think that's a great thing for our
industry it's not that everybody has to
pay $60 to go play games you can buy
downloadable games that are cheaper
they're free to play games out there on
other devices you see advertising funded
games and things this is just great the
kind of top of the top of the top from a
fidelity standpoint from a completeness
at launch standpoint or your $60 console
retail games and you know I think it's a
viable model and it's proving out to be
successful we've got publishers out
there having tremendous success we're
seeing great return from some of our
franchises that we're bringing back and
we're bringing them back as retail games
because there's there's strength in that
model and it's I think a good thing and
just now it's not all about $60 there's
just so many different ways that people
get involved in gaming so many different
business models and $60 I think will be
one of those things that's here to stay
as well as part of that well the
response to Halo Master Chief collection
from our briefing was pretty tremendous
we thought early on in the lifecycle of
a new console the ability to give people
access to all four games in an unlocked
way with all the multiplayer maps just a
great kind of book and beginning to to
the Xbox one generation the nice thing
about what 343 is doing with Halo is
they're taking a very long-term approach
to the franchise I don't think they're
overusing it they're finding in the say
in the book space they're finding the
stories that are best told in a linear
book form and that's where they're
focusing effort they're the stuff that
they're doing video with Ridley Scott
right now that'll be
coming out you know there it's really
about the the medium in which halo will
come out making it more the story and
the characters more accessible to more
people but everybody should know that
first and foremost halo is a
first-person shooter and that's where we
stay focused it has to succeed there
I like the Master Chief collection
coming out this November at $60 I think
that's a good value for Halo fans and
kind of lets them get their library on
Xbox one before halo 5 gets here and I
have a lot of trust that 343 is going to
manage that franchise over the long run
very carefully Gears of War is
incredibly important to us we as people
know we acquired that the intellectual
property from Epic Games in January we
hired Rod Fergusson who's been one of
the longtime creators on Gears of War he
joined the team up at black tusk I have
a review with them actually funny enough
next week maybe it's the 24th anyway
they're coming down to Redmond and I'm
going to see what with what we're
looking at for the next version of Gears
yeah this wasn't a show we weren't we
just wasn't the right time sure we could
have put together something with no
clear a ship date idea or something I
didn't want to do that
I said let's keep the team focused on
getting the right game idea and then
when we were there and we've got a story
to tell on stage we'll go do that but
this wasn't the right time for it but
I'm incredibly excited about what the
team can do and trying to take gears and
maybe get a little more gritty with the
the IP I think would be a good thing for
it a dream mashup game wow wow that's a
good question I'm gonna have to start
with like probably my most addictive
game that I've ever played in Robotron
so I'm going to start with a dual stick
shooter and then what would I want to
layer on if it had verticality because
it was all 2d and a different character
space I'm gonna go with Robotron
crackdown and I think if you had the
ability to kind of move around with a
dual stick and kind of a top-down view
but jump up on the top of buildings and
destroy buildings and stuff I just made
that up
but maybe we should do dual stick
crackdown meets Robotron